This is Kalle Koljonen
And Joonas Korhonen
Two Finnish national team badminton players
We'll challenge them to a game of badminton
But we will all play with table tennis rackets
Let's see who wins!
Power smash!
We were both going this way!
Nice!
I'm sorry!
No! How did I miss that?
How?
No pressure!
Good drop shot
Nice one!
Did you see the spinning?
Wow!
Where are you going Miikka?
There were some motions on that!
But there were no spin!
Good
That was good...
Maybe Miikka we should now use special strategy
Alright, so we have got special moves that we have been secretly practising!
This one is the Red Dragon!
Red Dragon!
Purple Frog!
This is going to be good!
Purple frog!
It worked!
Good job we had our secret practice session
Red dragon?
We'll use the red dragon!
Look! They are terrified!
We need a time out
Red dragon!
Move!
Why didn't you give me directions where to go?
Nice!
Good drop shot
Corner to corner!
I was so close to blocking it!
Right hand!
Left hand!
I made them run!
Quite intense!
At least we were working well there
Still in play!
I was there!
Good match!
Yea, thank you guys!
Good match, thank you!
That was fun!
Yea, actually really fun and the level was quite good!
Surprise prize for the winners
What is it?
Oh, nice!
You can put it on any table?
Yea, exactly
Thank you for coming in and challenge us!
It was an honour
It was a lot of fun!
why didn't you give me some directions
where to go
good match yeah thank you guys thanks
for
thank you that was fun yeah actually
really fun and the level was
actually quite good yeah surprise
surprise for the winners
what is it oh nice well you can put it
on
any table actually yeah exactly exactly
thank you for coming in then
yeah challenge us of course yeah it was
an honor yeah it was fun really yeah